oh hi thanks for joining us megabit i'm
peter brown I'm Sean McGinnis yeah you
are we're gonna play pilot wings today
we got about an hour uh this game came
out in 1990 1991 well 90 in Japan 91 in
North America and 92 in Europe somehow
they that really got the short end of
that one in fact yeah I used to play
this game a lot of the friend of mine
and I was awful at it and he I used just
watch him pass all the stages you show
my favorite memory of pilot wings is 10
minutes ago on the couch when you were
singing the theme song sounding like you
had a mouth full of potato chips so it
was accurate it was accurate you were
like BRR BRR yep just pretty good yeah
pretty good but we have the game it's
not just us acting like a bunch of
idiots for an hour well we are gonna
play some pilot will be some of that so
it throughout this game you basically
have to earn a bunch of different
licenses and to earn those licenses you
go through different trials with like
all sorts of different vehicles you've
got you know your your x wing you've got
a jetpack at one point a hang glider uh
hi Tony Oh Tony Tony Tony Bologna yeah
Tony will be your instructor if you
catch my drift whoa Tony's gonna teach
you a few things about life are you good
at piling Shawn I haven't played pilot
wings in about 15 years so yes so I like
to think I am pretty good at pilot wings
oh hi Shirley alright so this is surely
yep she's got a reasonable haircut yeah
and she's gonna teach you how to use the
L&R buttons milena miss good oh great
landing I think Shirley is tony with a
wig you think so thanks i don't think
that this whole thing is like an
elaborate hoax an elaborate like I don't
know psychological experiment
perpetrated by Tony it might be in like
his name might not even be
I think I have a theory that Tony is
like an eccentric billionaire yeah and
he buys all this [ __ ] so you know he
owns all this land out here in like
Nebraska and he just brings people here
and says if you don't pass my pilot
wings swear to God I swear to god oh god
this is so weird how is it you know 20
23 24 years later and we still don't
have human bird hybrid creatures is that
not disappointing I'm disappointed I'm
disappointed just heard about it no oh I
was watching that last event I was like
fun we don't have personal jetpacks
that's fine I understand but at the very
least we should have these human words
like Matt Smith 83 says tony is Tony
Stark could be like an evil version yeah
oh nice tie don't know how we can see
that soon or instead of using his
resources as and his money and his vast
intellect for good he uses it for evil
and just playing mind games with so much
evil like this is basically saw right
here these are elaborate traps that he's
Lord people in 20 really overshot that
one it's cool it's cool it's cool okay
no no no wow you really bungled this Wow
tony is not gonna be happy no no should
if anything just land on the GES target
there you go great landing very good
I'll admit it I'll admit it I'm
reluctant to say this because I think
you're a human monster but your skill is
improving all right who's Tony gonna be
next oh whoa Wow Tony's um he's gotten
into some hydrogen peroxide yeah started
to uh yeah wow yeah this looks like
somebody straight out of hotline Miami
yeah like this guy is like super coked
up and wants you to get revenge on some
Russian gangsters that turn to sour deal
on them
you want to the hang glider I'll try it
do it I got the controller all nice and
warm for you ha great yeah don't [ __ ]
this up am I [ __ ] it up I think yeah
you [ __ ] up no I'll dish it all to
catch that little lift right there where
do I have to go uh I think the target
over there yeah where that red dot is on
your radar no you that always freaks me
out she was like warning war now all
right here we go coming in hot which
target is it isn't that one yeah yellow
thing yeah all right here we go oh come
on I got this don't worry I'm coming in
this might be a hot landing but it's
gonna rate of descent two great wow you
were just going I bet they said that
about Neil Armstrong to his rate of
descent was too great but then he landed
on the GD moon here we go and this Oh
what what oh you look really good it
looks like you're in good shape all
right just remember oh you can do this
come on come out great landing okay wait
I noticed that you didn't land crumpled
up in a pile of human refuse Lance is
stoked about it oh yeah i think it's
moving so fast yeah that's tough that's
tough you can do it that's a real pickle
oh I'm not doing it Holly pickle now I'm
gonna sacrifice the whole run I do that
[ __ ] yeah to land in that small target
let's do that watch altitude this is
when you look at your altimeter oh
that's all right you got plenty of fuel
london problems coming oh you're going
for it Oh see those are the wild card
moves that always get you into trouble
oh no is not having it no no oh [ __ ]
okay come on come on come out oh wow
this is a haha a real hot man is it
going where is it going where is it
going where is it going okay it's going
to go I got to do this for Lance you can
vilanis once for Lance no Lance will
never be happiest look at that face I
know look at this man's face do you
really think that he can handle any more
failure that dude is gonna blow a gasket
but look look is back this piece of [ __ ]
right here honey yeah look no there's
nothing legit about tonight whoa whoa
take that back you take that back that
Tony is a human monster push a to open
what happens if you don't open the chute
Oh your body like explode like a garbage
bag full of hot meat um well cuz that
would be cool oh you gotta anticipate it
you gotta enter the ho ho Wow well that
was a real piece of [ __ ] landing welcome
i know a piece of [ __ ] behind the wheel
Tony you're such a dick look at the sky
oh wow look at him he's about to murder
something it puts the feet on the target
you gotta check oh look at my way Oh
what the dick I did Soho fine you were
fine up until you landed like a real
jerk landing failure zoo oof wow look
who's pissed I'll give you a hint what's
that sociopath on the screen right now
but what the [ __ ] my plan should have
skis a test
secret command oh the evil syndicate has
grown lately the evil syndicate has
grown they now have kidnapped a
government VIP that opposes them oh wow
our agent has penetrated their hideout
gross they await your rescue from the
heliport tonight please my brother
brother brother oh man snake oh I get it
you got it oh it's like a lock on 10 /
so this is basically the predecessor to
the ac-130 mission in call of duty sure
yeah what'swhat's call of duty call duty
is another video game created by Shigeru
Miyamoto oh cool khandelwal koji kondo
did this for this he did that hot call
duty theme song you know how that goes
call of duty kind of duty don't go TKE
of duty my god you gotta answer the call
dude it it's a that call when it goes
it's the car of duty [ __ ] you got shot
down would you come to where were you on
that way oh ah what Oh back into the
drinks a briny deep from whence you came
game over game over what are you not
gonna know you're not gonna promo my
show in the lower third bonito come on
we're having an intense argument with
our producers back there yeah they're
being real pieces of [ __ ] right now Bob
Jones we handle this yeah chachos yeah
we need you to drop the hammer alright
watch multiple players tuesday at 11am
pilot wings standard time on crit Wow
multiple players hosted by gamespot zone
and chris waters and other multiple
partners is a show about playing video
games featuring multiplayer
we had a lot of fun last week and by
that I mean this week playing star wall
just the tip just the tip we made a lot
of reach Oaks about that got it bar
touch the tip where's the other promos
bonito yeah bonito what we don't have a
promo for my show on here did renegade
yeah all right wednesdays at 11am
pacific standard time tune in to the
show and method it is a video game show
about me playing open-world games and
kind of just acting like a jerk to
people it's doing what you do where do
you want me to land on that patch of
snow that looks like a dog mmm it smells
going to go for anyone yeah as in life
in for the dog you can do it you can
land on that dong
oh this is gonna be messy I hope it's
just a big blood splatter oh here comes
here comes land right on that doh der oh
you went through guitar man that was
good all right you landed yeah I do it
on purpose all right honi megabit it's a
it's a show it's a show we play the game
we did a piling that was pilings you
want to remind folks when you're playing
next week next week and playing metal
warriors it's a lot like titanfall it's
actually exactly like tide falls what I
meant to say John watch system it's on
super nintendo nintendo us if you guys
are interested in titanfall and old
games that are kind of like it maybe
tune in and watch if you like old games
in general tune in every friday at 11am
I'm gonna start picking some more random
obscure games maybe you guys haven't
heard it before so we'll see how that
goes cool all right and make sure to
tune into multiple players tuesday at
11am pacific just chris waters the sean
method wednesdays at 11am pacific if and
random encounter with Danny O'Dwyer yeah
also 11am yes all right yeah in the
lobby and lobbies you p.m. on Tuesdays I
got that right this time cool I'm all
right all right thanks for watching guys
you